هذا ما عثرت عليه وكاله مكافحه الفساد
الاوكرانيه بعد مداهمه مكاتب بعض
المسؤولين الرافعين المستوى اكثر من
920,000 عرفنا اوكرانيه اي العمله الوطنيه
وحوالي 38,000 دولار امريكي تم اختلاسها
من ميزانيه الدوله من خلال ابرام عقود
باسعار مبالغ فيها من بين هؤلاء المسؤولين
نائب وزير التنميه الاوكراني الذي يشتبه
بتلقيه رشوه بقيمه 400,000 دولار مقابل
تمريره هذه العقود
فقال مجلس الوزراء الاوكراني نائب وزير
كان قد كشفه المكتب الوطني الاوكراني
لمكافحه الفساد اريد ان تكون هذه اشاره
الى كل اولئك الذين تنتهك وافعالهم
وسلوكهم مبدا العداله خلال السيف الماضي
خصص مجلس الوزراء الاوكراني اكثر من مليار
ونصف من العمله الوطنيه لشراء معدات
وتزويد السكاني بالكهرباء والمياه في
الشتاء بعد تدمير البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
لكن عددا من المس هنا اقدم على ابرام عقود
لشراء معدات ومولدات وكذلك منتجات غذائيه
مخصصه للجنود باسعار مبالغ فيها مع شركه
محدده مسبقا ما يترك الجنود الاوكرانيين
من دون معدات واطعام وفق المكتب الوطني
لمكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا التزام بقرار
الرئيس يواصل اكثر من 150 موظفا تحقيقاتهم
لتقديم جميع المطونين الى العداله حيث
تمكنوا من اعتقال احد اعضاء المجموعه ليلا
اثناء محولته عبور الحدود لمغادره البلاد